what was the purpose of re you know
writing this book you said
you know you kind of need to know my
background to know why i wrote this book
now that we know your background what
was your inspiration to want to write
that book
uh basically because i looked through
the history of contagion and if you
would permit me i'd love to share what i
found out with your listeners
please uh so so what are we talking
about here we're talking about
that the the normal observation that
you know a certain person gets sick in a
certain way
let's say a cold or a flu or that and
then somebody else in their
vicinity or their family or whatever
gets sick in the same way
and one says something was passed
between the first person
and another person and this is a very
normal
clear observation we've all had it and
in fact
interestingly you know it was first
described
at least 2 000 years ago by the ancient
greeks
they said there's something that's
passed between people
we don't know what it is you know they
thought the spirits or
who knows what uh they couldn't see
anything and
and then they thought there must be
something contagious and we go then for
about
1800 years without being able to find
the agent
now i would point out that this sort of
western science western medicine
is not the only stream of thought going
on
in those 2000 years right there's
chinese medicine there's probably
traditional iranian medicine there's
native american medicine there's
ayurvedic medicine
these are very old successful medical
systems
and what you find is none of them
thought diseases were contagious
none of them there is no concept in
chinese medicine
that something unseen passes from one
person to another
and in no other system did that exist
now of course that doesn't mean it's
true you know they could have all been
wrong
but when i looked into it i thought that
was sort of interesting
so then we get to around the 1800s and
now we're really talking about 1850
and there was what i call the first
eureka moment
right so we're thinking one person is
sick
another person gets sick there must be
something spread
and that observation is what's called
epidemiological observation
now i just want to point out something
here that
this contagion theory was applied to
to the following disease there was a
bunch of sailors who got sick
and one sailor after another got sick
and they their teeth fell
out and then they went into heart
failure and died and this happened in
the thousands and thousands of people
and it was usually one ship after
another and for a hundred years they
said this must be contagious
and then somebody ate a lime and the
whole thing went away because it turns
out it was scurvy
and the reason i point that out is
epidemiological observations
like this person got sick and then
somebody else got sick
is well accepted in medicine that is not
how we prove
causation and you hear this now all the
time well a lot of people in one place
got sick so it must be a virus
well a lot you know they blew a bomb off
in hiroshima a lot of people got sick
and nobody thinks that was a virus
or they'll say uh if it spreads from one
place to another that proves it's a
virus
so i'm sure you remember chernobyl there
was a nuclear accident a lot of people
died
it started spreading into eastern europe
and then western europe a lot of people
got sick
and as far as i could tell that's no
evidence that that was a virus
in other words the the the idea that a
lot of people in
iran or turkey or spain or
the nursing home or the cruise ship or
the whatever
got sick you know my aunt bessie went to
a party
those are epidemiological observations
the purpose of which is to generate
theories which can be
tested for causation period
and i would agree 100
that we had enough evidence with
contagion
that we should investigate for an
infectious cause
or an unseen agent now that's what
louis pasteur famously did he said
uh there's all these people and in fact
what he used was the case of sheep
and said there's all these sheep getting
sick
one sheep after another sometimes the
people who are handling the sheep got
sick
so there must be something uh that's
passed
they then it had an invented the
microscope
so the first eureka moment in history
then
is they could see this bacteria under
the microscope
and they saw the bacteria in the sheep
and they saw it
in the in the next sheep who got sick
end of story that's what caused the
sheep to get sick called anthrax
and but here's what happened then uh
pasteur isolated the anthrax bacteria
from the sheep
right so he took them out yeah and he
gave them to other sheep
and none of them got sick none of the
people got sick
now here's the way i think people should
understand this
imagine you have a cow and you don't
feed the cow proper food which is grass
right you feed it
cardboard and dead cow parts and you
know
and you soak in and glyphosate and ticks
poisons etc
all that stuff comes out in the milk now
then somebody drinks the milk and gets
sick that's contagion
right and then you look in the milk and
you see a bacteria called listeria
and you say okay that may be the
causative agent
and then you look in the stool of the
person and they also have listeria
end of story and so the listeria you
drank listeria it made you sick
now unfortunately though or maybe
fortunately there's another explanation
for that
which is the cow was sick the milk the
poisons went into the milk
the role of bacteria in nature is to
biodegrade
poisons right if you have a compost pile
and you put dead squirrels in it you'll
get bacteria to eat the squirrels
if you have a pond and you put poisons
in it you get
algae growth that eat the poisons if you
have a forest and you cut the trees down
the algae and the fungus and the
bacteria eat the dead trees
that's called biology that's called
bioremediation
so how do you know that the listeria
isn't there to to digest the poisons in
the milk
so we have two very clear explanations
for what may have happened
right it's either the bacteria or
it's the poison and the bacteria are not
causing anything
they're just helping you out by eating
the poisons
as they do in nature now what i tell
people is
this is what pasteur and his colleagues
did for 40 years because
there is a very simple way to sort this
out
all you have to do is isolate the
listeria from the milk
right you can't give them all the milk
because then you don't know if the
poison's in it
isolate the listeria give that to a
bunch of animals
see what happens that's what they did
for 40 years
and as far as i can tell from the
medical literature
no animal or person gets sick